les visages sont graves fermé ils
traduisent l'inquiétude et la colère de
ses enseignants tous travaillent dans
cette école de musique pour certaines
depuis des décennies une école gérée par
la communauté de communes yonne l'or en
très grave déficit qui a décidé de
fermer l'établissement
eux vont perdre leur emploi mais pense
d'abord aux 180 élèves et aux familles
les parents ne comprennent pas ils sont
dans la colère voilà et les enfants eh
bien ils pleurent ils peuvent même pas
réalisé cet événement
l'école de musique n'est pas la seule à
subir les mesures d'économies drastiques
la halte-garderie jusqu'ici udine et
rentrent va devenir sédentaire et les ex
bâtiment de gauthier acheté par la
comcom vont être vendus
la communauté de communes yonne nord
accuse un déficit de 3 millions et demi
d'euros
les administrés n'en reviennent pas
pourquoi des mères qui gèrent leur
commune n'arrive pas à gérer ensemble la
communauté de communes qu'est-ce qui se
passe si vraiment cet argent s'il ya un
tel déficit
où est passé d'où il vient nous allons
payer en fait une facture qui va être
très lourdes on se sent quelque part
coupable de la situation alors que nous
sommes pas épinglé par la cour régionale
des comptes la com com yonne nord va
augmenter ses impôts de 153% un chiffre
colossal mais qui va se traduire pour le
contribuable par une hausse de 15 % des
impôts locaux
une taxe sur les ordures ménagères va
aussi être créée la nouvelle fiscalité
si on ne la touche pas très rapidement
je suis pas certain de pouvoir assurer
les salaires on en est là c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui
on est vraiment sur un fonctionnement là
sur les trois prochains mois on est sur
un fonctionnement très très délicat jeu
page suit pas on est peut-être à la
veille de fermer des services possibles
le déficit serait la conséquence de
décennies de mauvaise gestion
mais pour cet ancien président il n'y a
eu ni malversations ni enrichissement
personnel
est-ce que j'ai volontairement ordonné
de mettre sous le tapis
ce qu'on appelle des restes à réaliser
puisque c'est comme ça que ça s'appelle
la réponse est non réponse est non
puisque j'ai moi même découvert
l'ampleur du problème
quelques plusieurs semaines après
notamment lorsque la chambre régionale
des comptes avait été saisi la
communauté de communes yonne nord ne
devrait pas être placée sous tutelle de
l'état
elle va porter plainte et atteindre de
l'enquète toute la lumière sur les trois
millions et demi d'euros de déficit